new information about the deadly dive
boat fire in California raises concerns
about what are the crew broke any laws
the wreckage of the Concepcion was
pulled from the water near Santa Barbara
yesterday Jonathan Vigliotti has the new
details on the day crews lifted the
doomed dive boat near Santa Cruz Island
federal investigators raised new
concerns about what led to the fire that
sank it I'm pleased to report that the
salvage operations have so far been
successful an NTSB report says all six
crew members on the boat were asleep
when the fire broke out in the early
morning of September second
investigators say one crew member was
required to be awake and on Patrol five
crew members jumped into the water and
survived but 34 people were trapped
below deck all of them died this was a
very challenging case all round the
location the relatively remote location
22 miles or so away from the coastline
the charred remains of the Concepcion
will now be carefully examined
investigators are considering whether
lithium-ion batteries used to power
phones and cameras overheated and caused
the fire the tragedy prompted the US
Coast Guard to reissue its emergency
water safety guidelines which include
limiting the unsupervised charging of
lithium-ion batteries and power strips
for CBS this morning
I'm Jonathan Vigliotti